hey guys welcome back to another video
we're going to be talking about the
whiteout summary today and then kind of
a few questions regarding this channel
and then if the if for honor is kind of
failing as of right now so let's kind of
get into this basically the what
happened on June 17th of Saturday and it
wasn't exactly received well players
weren't receiving rewards after matches
and then people also couldn't do their
dailies for example the daily that was
that day I believe it was executing five
players I executed all five of my
players with no bushi immediately in one
game and I came back after the game to
get the reward and it said I did zero
out of five I was very confused but 400
did say that they are they noticed it
and then they did fix it within three to
four hours but that turned off players
immediately such as a couple of my
friends who were playing with me at the
time noticed that they didn't get their
awards and immediately didn't play until
this morning so they completely missed
out on the whole whiteout event some of
the players can't even play because of
connection which is an obvious issue and
then just by player balancing which they
can't stand it which is very obvious but
now it comes with a question is for
honor failing now with the whole
whiteout not working I can kind of tell
that it's slowly starting to decline we
did get those number we people have
numbers of what the Steam players are
yes there was that article the 95% of
the player base going down but that was
cruelly only on PC but some of it may be
true something might not be but if it is
that's very bad yes there is the other
council players but we still have the
only numbers we have and it's just it's
not looking good for this game do I wish
that this game would be way better and
have a [ __ ] ton of players playing every
day yes I would love this game I've been
waiting for some type of medieval game
to come out and I've been hyped as [ __ ]
ever since I saw a beta gameplay an
alpha gameplay for this game I think I
have been covering this game since beta
so I've been extremely ecstatic for this
game but every single day it seems like
it's worse and worse the reddit all
comes up with weird I hear the reddit
just keeps coming up with ideas on how
to fix it no one's listening the
toxicity it's just this whole jumbled
mess the player base is divided for the
black and the white out then you got
other people that just don't care enough
and it's just really not looking good
now I had other ideas
this game and I was going to start
covering two other games and this is
where I'm going to start getting flamed
for this so I do apologize but basically
I've been seeing I've been seeing a lot
of gameplay on absolve err and law
breakers two very new IP games that look
very promising lawbreakers is kind of
your new arena shooter kind of like
quake but a updated version of quake if
you took out clicked champions kind of
like an Unreal Tournament and then
absolve er is kind of like what for
honor could have been with like very
paint ish like beautiful-looking
aesthetics and graphics was kind of like
a for honor kind of combat system but
without majority of it being swords and
weapons more of like hand-to-hand combat
I'm going to get flamed for this because
while I was at work today I was kind of
just chillin during break time and I
noticed a fellow four hundred youtuber
big sobs Bowser Phoenix has been head
did this video already and no I'm not
copying him just by doing these types of
topics but people believe I'm copying
him because a lot of ideas or I just
like to steal people's content that is
not what I plan to do I've never wanted
to do that it is by mere coincidence
that me and him are doing absolve err
and lawbreakers because from the looks
of his video he doesn't want to cover
those games as well I have no problem
with boss and I don't think has a
problem with me but a couple of the subs
do have a problem with me doing stuff
that he likes it's it is a free world I
can do what I want but I'm not going to
be that [ __ ] that just basically
blatantly copies exactly what his video
is and I've been getting a lot of hate
for that but I'm just going to push
through that and do what I feel but just
that's what I wanted to do lawbreakers
is going to come out with a beta June 28
you can pick it up you can pick up a
beta key if you look around there should
be a website with a beta key somewhere I
don't know the exact site if I do it'll
be in the description you can pick up a
beta key on PC and ps4 and absolve er
has yet to be announced her beta yet so
I was hopefully when the beta comes out
I'll give you some gameplay of those
volt those games and then we can talk
about those I'm not stopping for honor
not for a while I'll still cover the dev
streams also cover the patch note I
can't wait to see all the comments now
oh you're copying vows Phoenix straight
coincidence that me and him happen to be
covering due to very highly anticipated
games there are other content creators
out there that are copying or that are
doing those games
well some people I'm getting slight
blamed for it but I thought I really had
to say guys so basically is for on are
going to fail I hope not I hope it
doesn't this game this video was
completely off script if it sounded
really shitty I'm sorry I just need to
get this out and I wanted to share my
thoughts with all of you but hopefully
you all did enjoy this video and I'll
see you all in the next video guys peace
out